as capacity restrictions are loosened
and more and more people
get vaccinated some club sport teams are
asking for a chance to play
full contact club sports such as group
cheer basketball water polo
currently are prohibited from competing
kate houston spoke to one local team
who says they should be reclassified i
love being with
my team through all the wins and losses
it's always fun saul biddle has played
for team vegas water polo for six years
he says the current classification of
water polo as high risk because it's a
contact
sport has made it difficult for his team
mentally
there's a weight in our shoulder right
now the club team is only allowed to do
conditioning based practices
no contact there's no more adversity in
practice everything's separate
everything's individual
but we are a team we're not an
individual sport so they're missing on
that aspect of it mark saint john coach
of team vegas water polo has brought his
concerns to the state which recently
reclassified the cross as a minimal
contact sport
st john is asking for water polo to be
reclassified as well
citing competition and practices take
place in chlorinated water
we're not arguing that we're not a
contact sport
our argument is that even though we are
a contact sport the environment in which
we play in
makes it a safe sport st john has
recently hosted tournaments in utah
requiring two negative covid tests
before competition
he's asking for in-state competition to
be allowed under the same strict
protocols
pointing out some local hockey clubs
have already been able to do so
we are willing to go through any hoop
follow any guidelines for our kids
we just want to give want to be given
the chance to do so overall he says this
is for his young athletes who want to
get back to the sport they love
we're just looking at the future and
hoping that
we we can get back to our regular
practices because we miss him
kate houston 8 news now such a great
sport water polo this week the state's
covid response team was asked about
modifying the current guidelines for
youth and adult sports at this point
they are continuing to monitor cases and
taking
input from public health professionals
denise